today on the matt walsh show the left
circles the wagons to defend poor 100
billion disney from the mean
conservatives criticizing it also the
governor of texas ships illegal
immigrants to dc and kim kardashian runs
to the defense of a woman who beat her
two-year-old daughter to death another
example of twisted left-wing compassion
and what it looks like plus a pastor at
a church in iowa offers a prayer to the
quote god of pronouns speaking of
pronouns the republican governor of utah
is now introducing himself with his
pronouns once you sacrifice your dignity
on the altar of leftist appeasement you
never get it back we'll discuss all that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you've heard me talk about how
important it is to have a vpn to protect
your online privacy but choosing a vpn
you trust is equally as important now i
like to do uh research on my sponsors
and i only recommend brands to my
listeners that i believe it i can say
with full confidence that expressvpn is
the best vpn on the market here's why
first expressvpn doesn't log your
activity online lots of cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn does not do
this they even developed a technology
trusted server that makes their vpn
servers incapable of storing any data at
all second expressvpn is lightning fast
i've tried many vpns in the past and
they can sometimes slow my connection
but expressvpn is always blazing fast it
lets me
stream videos in hd quality with zero
buffering the last thing that really
sets expressvpn apart is how easy it is
to use you don't need any technical
skills to get it set up trust me if you
did i wouldn't be able to do it you just
fire up the app tap one button to
connect and that's it even your
grandparents could do it so protect
yourself with the vpn that i use and
trust use my link expressvpn.com walsh
today get an extra three months free on
a one year package that's
expressvpn.com walsh visit
expressvpn.com walsh to learn more
so there's no doubt in my mind that
conservatives right now are making
progress in the culture war it hasn't
been an easy romp by any means
and these recent victories come after
about four or five decades of near
constant defeat
we have a whole lot of territory still
left to recover and it will take a very
long time to win it all back if we do um
we're gaining ground fitfully and with
difficulty but
we are gaining it
there's no guarantee that the trend
continues we do have quite a lot stacked
against us still we're advancing and
that's obviously a very good thing the
question is why is this happening and
how i think it's worth reflecting on
that it's not as though we've witnessed
any sort of mass defection with leftists
leaving their degenerate worldview and
satanic philosophies behind in droves
and experiencing some kind of mass
conversion of hearts and mind there have
been some examples of that kind of thing
but it's still relatively rare overall
i'm guessing that if you polled an
average sampling of americans on most of
the big social issues the percentages
would break down about the same today as
they did last year the year before that
the progress on the right has not been
so far in convincing huge numbers of
people on the other side to come over
here rather it has been in convincing
and motivating
our own side to get engaged and focus on
what matters you know they say that uh
you shouldn't preach to the choir but
i've always hated that expression oh
you're preaching to the choir because in
fact the people in the choir are the
first ones you need to preach to
if they aren't on your side if you don't
have the choir on your side then it's
going to be hard to reach anybody else
in the congregation not to mention
people outside of the congregation
and so our recent victories have mostly
been due to rallying our own side i
think awakening ourselves from our own
self-imposed stupor
at the beginning of the year it was the
school board movement
now it's not that most parents prior to
this past year were in favor of the
schools racially and sexually
indoctrinating their kids
it's just that so many of them weren't
paying enough attention or any attention
they weren't focusing on it
year after year millions of kids were
sent into government education
facilities for seven hours a day their
parents hoping that they'd receive a
competent education certainly
opposing in theory the left-wing
brainwashing that happened within the
system but not really mobilized or
motivated to do anything about it
and that changed this year
parents weren't suddenly convinced to
oppose the brainwashing of their
children most of them always opposed
that hypothetically but they were
emboldened to finally show up and make a
scene and make their voices heard
and the system was so caught off guard
and terrified by this sudden
mobilization
that they labeled us all domestic
terrors
the system was running scared and still
is and it should be
i think we're seeing something similar
with the anti-grooming laws and the
backlash against disney all these things
of course related yesterday there was a
protest outside of disney headquarters
in burbank california
a disney employee actually addressed the
crowd outside disney headquarters uh
listen to this
and i'm a cast member here at the well
for disneyland actually i've been with
them for quite a long time and it's
gotten very political and it's gotten
very hard to be who you are it's gotten
very hard to be someone who has
conservative values someone who believes
in the right to choose somebody who
believes that it's okay to stand up for
righteousness
it is okay to stand up for righteousness
to any disney cast members that are
afraid to be bold that are afraid to be
courageous stand up
you look at the crowd by the way i think
it's worth noting that it's not just a
bunch of
old people nothing nothing nothing
against old people but you know for for
a long time i can remember even my my
grandmother used to write letters to
disney when she was concerned about the
messaging and some of the uh some of the
disney films she was ahead of her time
and for a long time it was you know
there have always been conservatives
complaining about disney and noticing
the messaging there but for a long time
it was at least the stereotype it was
mostly like older people and
grandparents who were worried about
disney uh what you see here is a whole
bunch of young people in that crowd as
well
who have awakened to this issue and
you've got a disney employee addressing
this crowd of protesters outside of
disney headquarters and urging them to
stand up for righteousness
that's not the kind of scene
i thought we would see at the beginning
of this year it's also not a scene the
left and the media ever anticipated
and just like they did with the school
board movement they're once again
running scared they're panicking
flailing about
articles and cable news segments
vacillate between mocking conservatives
for criticizing disney and then also
accusing us of participating in cancel
culture against the company
that's one of the big lines right now is
that this is this is cancel culture
against disney
now as to that claim
just to be clear about this it is by
definition not possible for a
multinational mega corporation to be the
victim of cancel culture
cancel culture is a tool of such
institutions cancel culture is an
institutional
tool
you can't really cancel someone without
the power of the institutions on your
side
the institutions cannot be the target of
cancer culture as much as i might wish
that they could be
they can however be criticized
and protested and boycotted and that's
what's happening here and for good
reason
but the institutions protect their own
which is why the media is running to
disney's defense here's humpty dumpty on
cnn valiantly uh coming to the defense
of the poor persecuted multi-billion
dollar corporation let's listen to that
in the united states we're seeing a
theme of the midterm elections emerging
it's the way you can see a wave start to
form far from shore before it breaks on
the beach the theme the talking point on
the right is about protecting kids from
the dangers of
the walt disney company
really
but disney's just a stem a stand-in it's
just a symbol for something bigger a
conservative backlash to growing
acceptance of gay and transgender people
a conservative fear that traditional
beliefs are being trampled on and there
are entire networks that program to this
fear and many politicians that react to
it that's the story here as this cnn.com
reporting says three months into the new
year lawmakers in dozens of states have
introduced a slew of bills that could
limit the rights of lgbtq americans
some of those bills are framed as
parental rights bills opponents say
they're really actually anti-gay bills
and it's easy to picture this battle
continuing right through the midterm
elections but for folks who aren't
partisan warriors this battle is
incredibly disheartening
i spoke with a disney executive who's
caught in the middle of it right now and
they said you know disney's brand for
decades has been family friendly and has
been gay friendly and that hasn't been
in conflict
that need not be in conflict
but the media organs that profit from
conflict are on a crusade now working
overtime to demonize disney claiming the
company is indoctrinating and
sexualizing children through movies and
tv shows
now you notice the text on the screen
right there it says focus on parental
rights chips away at gay rights
the left is now positioning parental
rights and gay rights as two opposite
competing things that's how they're
positioning
now this is this is without question
the most suicidal and self-destructive
kind of political messaging that lgbt
activists could ever possibly devise
i mean they shout you have to choose
between your precious parental rights
and my gay rights choose i say well um i
guess i'll just take my parental rights
in that case if i mean if that if if you
insist on me choosing if it's got to be
one or the other uh yeah i'll take the
parental rights sure for sure no
question especially since you apparently
believe that you have the gay right to
sexually indoctrinate my kids
so that's that's not a difficult choice
for me to make
as for disney keep in mind
that while the media
throw up their hands and say why do you
care so much about disney leave disney
alone what'd they ever do to you
ah you silly conservatives making such a
big deal out of disney
they were the ones who brought disney
into this to begin with they insisted
that disney take a stand on the florida
parental rights bill
conservatives didn't insist on that
i don't remember a single conservative
before disney said anything there were
no conservatives insisting
that um that disney support the bill
no nobody on the right was was saying
where's disney on this why aren't they
supporting the brent rights bill we were
fine with disney saying nothing at all
about the subject in fact i would have
preferred that
the left demanded it
and when they got what they wanted and
disney came out fully in favor of the
sexual indoctrination and grooming of
preschoolers
we
reacted with appropriate levels of
disgust
and we now say that if disney is
committed to this path then we obviously
can't allow the company anywhere near
our children
considering that disney has been
committed to ideologically brainwashing
kids for many years we should have come
to this conclusion sooner as
conservatives but better late than never
never i suppose
the left can of course mock us for
caring so much about disney even though
they were the ones who spent months
insisting that disney's opinion on the
florida bill is of utmost importance
and now they switch course and they say
the opposite this is all part of the
we're used to this trend this is a
common trend i remark on all the time
with with the left where they demand
that we care about a certain thing
they shove it in our face they scream
about it you must care about this
disney's opinion on the florida bill we
this is really important
and then we say okay well we
care but we've reached the opposite
conclusion from you
and then and then suddenly they say well
why do you care so much it doesn't
matter
they're actually scrambling
what they're really worried about is
that they know we're over the target you
know
just as we were with the school boards
for years we allowed entertainment
companies like disney
we allowed them open and non-stop access
to our kids
allowed our kids to consume their
content and i say our and we you know in
a universal sense
um
some of us were a little bit more
discerning about it but generally
speaking
parents allowed their kids to just sit
there and consume disney content all day
without without scrutinizing the
messages that the content contained
and that was an incredibly valuable tool
for the left
now they see that we're finally awake
and it's not gonna be quite so easy
anymore to indoctrinate our kids
and that terrifies them
and again it should
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i want to start right off the bat with
this governor greg abbott in texas i
think with perhaps the highlight of his
tenure in texas i just i love everything
about this personally
let's listen to him first
crossing the border
from mexico into texas
and at this time i'm going to sign my
directive
to colonel mccraw the director of the
texas department of public safety
to get that project underway immediately
for the zero tolerance and the
inspections that will be taking place
second
to help local officials
whose communities are being overwhelmed
by hordes of illegal immigrants who are
being dropped off by the body
administration
texas
is providing charter buses
to send these illegal immigrants who
have been dropped off by the
administration
to washington d.c
we are sending them to the united states
capitol where the body administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border
to
get that going i'm going to sign a
letter to chief nem kid with the texas
division of emergency management who
will be in charge of this operation
together
and to recap on these
what colonel mccraw is charged to do is
uh in this letter i say that i hereby
direct the texas department of public
safety to conduct
enhanced safety inspections of vehicles
as they cross international points of
entry into texas
this is great i mean i i think it's a
this is a wonderful idea it's the kind
of thing that
in previous years you might talk about
and it wouldn't be nice if they would
just load up all the illegals and dump
them right in dc right on the right on
the laps of all the politicians who have
devised these open border laws to begin
with uh you talk about it and then you
don't expect any that it's actually
going to happen because usually the
republican party doesn't have the guts
to do anything like that uh not nearly
bold enough but
so this that's exactly what what uh
governor abbott's going to do
now of course
obviously this is being criticized on
the left and even even some people on
the right some people even that i
respect on the right
who i wouldn't call milk toast by any
means i've seen a few
criticizing this saying well you're
using people as pawns here i'm a little
uncomfortable with it um
but i think you got to get over that
this is first of all this is not greg
abbott
using
illegal immigrants as pawns
that's the democrat party that's that's
joe biden
that has been the official democrat
policy
for years
to use illegal immigrants to open up the
floodgates allow them in
they have political reasons to do it
they of course don't care about the
humanity of these people
they don't care about their safety or
well-being
they did they wouldn't be implicitly and
often explicitly encouraging them to
embark on this dangerous journey across
the desert
um
in the first place if they actually
cared about their safety and well-being
so i think for for greg abbott it's
pretty pretty simple
like you
people in the buy administration you
want them coming in so we're going to
send them up to you you figure out what
to do with them
why should this be our problem
see this is supposed to be your job in
the federal government to protect the
borders if you're not doing it
then the consequences should be felt by
you not by us
and at any rate if you're on the left
you should totally support a plan like
this because uh
because
you know texas is a is a red state that
means it's systemically racist well the
whole country really is but especially
in texas of all places right so so
wouldn't wouldn't you want the illegals
to be rescued from texas and sent up to
the warm embrace of washington dc where
everything is perfect and safe and
wonderful
you know the people advocating for open
borders this has always been the case
you know just like with abortion as
ronald reagan famously pointed out all
the people who support abortion happen
to be alive
right so it doesn't affect them
they already made it through the
gauntlet of the modern womb and they
they managed to survive and now they're
turning back around and you know in
effect like pulling the ladder up behind
them and saying oh all the rest of those
babies you can kill and a similar thing
with the open borders the people who
advocate for open borders
and have these open border policies in
place they for the most part don't live
anywhere near the border
washington dc is
if you're familiar with the geography
united states not anywhere near the
southern border
so they don't feel the effects of it
they're also politicians i mean they
work in uh in industries where they
don't have to worry about their jobs and
opportunities being taken by illegals so
they don't feel the effect of it at all
they're able to sit on their comfortable
perch
and let everybody else suffer because of
their policies
that's leftist leadership in a nutshell
so here all he's saying is this is your
problem you created it you want these
people to come in
in the first place
unfettered unvetted
you deal with it
i like it i think it's a great idea
i don't like this though kim kardashian
has been on a campaign to free the worst
people in the world from prison um or at
least to free them from the full
consequences of their crimes especially
if the consequence is the death penalty
because that is a
a consequence in at least still some
states in the union
and if you live in one of those states
you know that or you ought to know that
you know before you choose to commit a
brutal crime you
you know what you're getting yourself
into you know what the consequence is
you commit the crime and and uh now you
have to pay the price for it
it's really something that you chose
so that's the thing about the death
penalty is that you
the individual who chooses to commit
if they didn't choose to commit the
crime i mean if they're if it's decided
this person is completely insane doesn't
have free will then we already
um it already is the policy that those
people are not going to be executed so
if they cho if they choose to commit it
they also chose the consequence they
chose the punishment because they knew
what it was going to be
kim kardashian doesn't like that though
and so this has been her this has been
her hobby horse for a while now
um and look she has not done anything
important or useful or good in her life
and she's decided to make this her thing
this is like her charitable endeavor
defending the worst scum on planet earth
but what we have to remember is that of
course this is all about her so here she
is
in an interview recently talking about
how the um the recent execution of a
criminal impacted her personally because
again it's all about her listen
i was working on the brandon bernard
case and he was in fact executed and
i remember crying and
feeling
so helpless because it was his last
phone call and he was telling me like
don't cry it's gonna be okay and
you know hearing that he was worried
that he would be claustrophobic in the
chair
and then
on his last call when he was in the
execution room said please tell kim i'm
not claustrophobic it's okay
and like moments like that i'm like if
only someone could see my day i'm like
hysterically crying calling every
governor that i could possibly imagine
to try to stop someone's execution and
then i have to run into you know a skims
fitting and i'm fitting and i'm crying
and i can't really get my work done
i was tough because she had to go to a
skins fitting the other guy was being
executed but she was crying at her skins
fitting
the level of narcissism required to make
somebody else's execution about you
is uh i mean it's off the charts
and now she's back at it so she tweeted
this way this is what she tweeted
i recently just read about the case of
melissa luccio and wanted to share her
story with you
so remember she just read about the case
just read about it and already she's
decided she's she has passed her own
verdict
she says she's been on death row for
over 14 years for her daughter's death
that was a tragic accident
jess found out about it
you know probably read the wikipedia
article or something and has already
decided that um melissa luccio who was
convicted of murdering her two-year-old
daughter actually was a tragic accident
kardashian goes on to say that lucia's
two-year-old daughter
died from falling down the steps
that's the that's the claim anyway um
actually it died two days after falling
down the steps allegedly but nobody ever
sought medical attention for her
but it was all it was all a terrible
misunderstanding on an accident
um kim kardashian actually deleted this
tweet sort of confusingly deleted it but
is still openly advocating for lucio and
defending her
hasn't really explained why she deleted
tweets
here are the facts though and kardashian
is not the only person coming to melissa
luccio's defense and saying that she's
uh you know she's really the victim here
and and it would be a terrible injustice
executor so here's here's what happened
i'll just break it down quick summary
um
her two-year-old child was um
founded
in in her home
two days after this supposed fall
now already this raises some questions
like your child fell down the steps
and was it turns out fatally wounded
and you never sought medical attention
for her
that raises some serious questions
then you get some answers to those
questions when you find out that there
was bruising all over her body
clumps of hair pulled out of her head
and bite marks on her body as well and a
broken arm
the physician at the hospital said it
was the worst case of abuse he'd ever
seen in his life
pathologist
looked at the autopsy said the autopsy
showed that she died from abuse
she did not die from
you know a fall down the steps
also keep in mind that
she fell down the steps quote unquote is
that's like the classic
abuser
rationalization that's the excuse that i
don't know every abuser in history has
given
or at least 90 percent of them
fell down the steps how often have we
heard that one
and
falling down the steps how does that
result in bite marks how does that
result in your your hair falling out
and once again even if somehow in some
unbelievable
coincidence
the child happened to fall down the
steps in such a way as to cause all of
these injuries i don't know how that
could even
possibly be the case
but then then she would have been very
visibly
and grievously injured so why didn't you
seek medical attention
there's no explanation for this and then
you find out that lucio actually
confessed under interrogation
that she's that
that she's responsible for the death of
her child
now yes now this this interrogation this
confession is being um used by lucio's
defenders to say that uh to
to say that the whole thing was was
invalid
because she confessed under it was like
five she was in she was being
interrogated for several hours like five
six hours
and she denied it
many times before she finally admitted
it
and so our defenders are saying well
there's five hours of interrogation she
and then she confessed
well that's what an interrogation is
that's why you call it an interrogation
what
how do you think an interrogation is
supposed to work are the cops supposed
to just like
you've got a dead child here
with all of these wounds on her on her
body
and you bring in the mother and you sit
her down and you say uh did you kill
your child and she says no and then you
just say oh okay well never mind then
no obviously they had especially when
the when the when the
the physician at the hospital tells you
that this is the worst case of physical
abuse of a child he's ever seen in his
life
and then given all the other
circumstances that's going to make you
as as a police officer
as an investigator very very suspicious
about this woman
and so of course you're going to
interrogate her for five hours
interrogate her for 15 hours
until you get an explanation that makes
sense
i don't even understand this whole thing
about
this is so common that we we hear uh as
well the person only confessed after x
number of hours of interrogation that's
the point of the interrogation
are you suggesting that the cops should
just take the first answer they get
she killed her child and she
obviously she didn't want to admit to it
right away she would prefer not to admit
to it
she doesn't want to go and be in jail
for the rest of her life or get executed
so it part of the interrogation is
breaking through those initial
psychological defenses to try to get to
the truth that's what it's that's the
point
uh so to me this is very this is very
clear cut but kim kardashian
you know spent spent five six seconds
reading about the issue and decided that
uh melissa luccio is
is really the victim here
a woman convicted of
brutally
beating her two-year-old to death
is the person we're supposed to feel
sorry for
sorry that's just i i don't i don't have
that in me and it's not because i'm
callous
i think the callousness is all on the
other side
you know you this is this is misdirected
sympathy
this is this kind of twisted form of
compassion that you get from the left
you get from people like kim kardashian
and it's it's um
among other things it's an easy kind of
compassion because she doesn't feel like
if you're a morally decent person you
should feel this intense
unbridled
revulsion and anger
at
this kind of violence against a child
i mean you should have a rage boiling
inside you at the idea that a child was
beaten to death
and and that's what that's what a
morally healthy person experiences
that's the hatred we talked about
a couple days ago
if you're a loving and compassionate
person you should have hatred in your
heart for
things like this
the brutal victimization of a child you
should hate that you should hate that
with every fiber of your being
now by all appearances kim kardashian
doesn't have that inner she just doesn't
she doesn't really feel much about the
fact that about the victims and the
terrible things that were done to them
and so it's easy for her to have quote
compassion for the
for the criminals
because she doesn't feel any anger about
what they did
she doesn't feel any righteous justified
anger that's where the compassion comes
from it's it really comes it you know
what it comes from it comes from
indifference
it's not compassion it's indifference
and we tend to confuse those two things
a lot in this culture
there are a whole lot of people who are
very indifferent to injustice and they
get away with
positioning that indifference as
compassion all right i got to play this
for you this is a presbyterian church in
iowa um
female pastor
no coincidence there giving her version
of a prayer
and uh just listen to this
oh god of pronouns
we give praise to the great one
the one who was identifiable as god
i am what i am you say
the great they
the incarnate he and she
the god of trans being
impregnating mary
fathering god
breastfeeding god of many breasts
you shadow you shatter all stereotypes
making every single person
male
and female
male and female
non-binary in your image
exactly in your image
spectrum
rainbow god who put your promise for
non-violence in the symbol for queer
love
before humanity knew
because you knew
who had joseph who could not sleep with
a woman in a beautiful lady's cloak
perhaps of rainbow colors
before we knew
you knew
god of pronouns who said you can call me
he or she or they
whatever makes you feel closest to me
the great they
that's how she refers to god
uh the god of pronouns now
first of all it's not a it's actually
not a coincidence that the um that this
is a female pastor
saying all this not to suggest that
the bad pastors are always female
there's a lot of there's a lot of
a lot of a lot of bad men leading
churches as well in this country and
across the west and across the world
but it's also not a coincidence that the
craziest and most heretical stuff
usually happens at churches with female
pastors that is not a coincidence and
the reason it's not a coincidence is
that churches
which that have
already bought into feminism
were destined to continue the slide into
what we're seeing now
that's the connection there
and what we see there is
um what we've seen in in many churches
again across the west just this is a
this is a very uh one of the more
shocking examples of it but
this is god
made in the image of
man
rather than man made in the image of god
that's the way she's she she in this
church
she is trying to remake god in her own
image
in the image of what she thinks humanity
is
it's a it's a complete inversion
of the actual message of the bible
how the bible begins
male and female he created them and she
even says that there's there's one talk
about shocking there's one surprising
moment where she says you made them male
and female and you stopped and said hold
on a second you're admitting that much
at least then she continues and intersex
and non-binary
no actually um that's
not in the scripture at all in fact it
says that male and female he created
them there's there are no other
categories provided
and that's not just in the beginning of
the bible it's all throughout the bible
there are many exhortations given to men
and to women and there's never a third
there's never a time where oh yeah and
the third category over here here's what
you should do
so we see her in real time rewriting the
bible
and trying to rewrite god remake god in
her own twisted self-image
speaking of twisted uh i got to play
this for you too
sean penn appeared on
hannity this week and
talk about things you you may not have
expected in the past um
there was a time when this combination
would be somewhat unthinkable having
sean sean penn and and uh
and sean hannity getting along but he
appeared on hannity uh this week to to
complain
that countries are not more willing to
use nuclear weapons listen
the ukrainians we saw and talked to
whether they were in uniform out of
uniform school teachers even children
this extraordinary courage that's come
up and he it was in his eyes and
it is clear to me that the ukrainians
will win this the question is at what
cost did they have in those early hours
i know that trump gave them javelins i
know that they had some defenses but if
you go back to the budapest agreement
they were at the time the third largest
nuclear power in the world
and they they made an agreement that
they'd give those weapons to the
to russia to be destroyed in exchange
for protection from russia great britain
and the us
uh
lesson to be learned here don't give up
your nuclear weapons if you have them
because you can't believe people like
vladimir putin why even countries that
have nuclear weapons can remain
intimidated to use them and we're seeing
that now with our own country and i fear
what that legacy is going to be we don't
no one wants to see a nuclear i don't
want to see one nobody at the same time
if only one bully is going to be able to
use those weapons as a threat we got to
rethink what we're doing
just to be clear here this is um
sean penn who pretends to want world
peace and and all of that and global
harmony um
he's disappointed
he's disappointed that western countries
are not more eager to use nuclear
weapons
this is him he's openly saying like i i
he he thinks that we shouldn't nuke
russia that's what he's saying
and he's given a platform to say that
absolute
madness
speaking of madness one of the things
before we get to the
comment section this is from travel and
leisure um i saw this this article
making the rounds yesterday and uh i was
quite unsettled by it it says
in the middle of a sweltering summer you
can bet that pretty much everyone has
their air conditions running as cold as
possible however according to consumer
reports most of us are probably running
our air conditioners at the wrong
temperature which wastes energy and
causes our utility bills to sort
energy star came out with
recommendations for setting your air
conditioner so that you can save money
and use energy efficiently
now and then they they wanted to talk to
experts
because we need experts to tell us
what
you know what our thermostat should say
we need we need experts to tell us what
is most comfortable for us
and it says that according to experts
it's recommended you set your air
conditioning at 78 degrees when you're
home and awake and it gets worse
if you leave your home
set your unit to 85 degrees when you're
asleep
set it to 82 degrees
the experts say
now the experts have been
disproven and invalidated
and uh and shamed and humiliated in many
different ways over over the last uh few
years especially
like i think in no example more stark
than this one
when they're telling us to set our air
conditioning at 82 degrees when you're
sleeping
now let me look this is this is actually
i'm the expert on this and i'll tell you
what the where your thermostat should be
um throughout the day basically your
house should never be
especially if i'm coming over to visit
your house should never be warmer than
68 degrees that should be the that's the
baseline all the time it should never
get more than 68 degrees
it doesn't matter the season
when you're sleeping though it should be
it's got to be as cold as it will
possible it should be
it should be so cold that if your
blankets come off in the middle of the
night you might you might die of
hypothermia in your sleep that's how
cold it should be get it as cold as it
could possibly be
that's that is the correct answer
take it from me not these so-called
experts all right let's get out of the
comment section
elizabeth ball says the definition of a
groomer is someone who uses subtle
techniques to prepare slash guide a
child towards something later if they
don't think that they're grooming kids
to see gender and sex as fluid and to
see all kinds of sex as good sex what do
they think they're doing
of course why don't even ask they don't
think about what they're doing at all
they simply comply
with the silent commands of their
masters below uh no they they know that
grooming is exactly what they're doing
now that's that's probably not the
language they would choose to use that's
not what they call it amongst themselves
um they would they they use euphemisms
for it
that's what we always have to keep in
mind about the left is that they
everything they do they cover in
euphemisms
and so they're going to use a lot of
euphemisms here one would be just
education they would probably call it
but when you are
here's grooming okay
when you are
in indoctrinating children and you know
inducting them into
a certain
sexual view of life and a certain
certain sexual lifestyle
and not only are you doing that
but you're doing it
without their parent
parents consent
and while telling and in fact oftentimes
telling the kids don't tell your parents
about this that's grooming
i mean
any time a there's there's almost never
going to be an occasion
where it's going to be appropriate for
you as an adult
to go to a child and have a conversation
with them
that you don't want their parents to
know about
now the only time i can conceive of when
that would be appropriate is if the
child is is the victim of abuse at home
and is
coming to you and then you're gonna get
the authorities involved
anything outside of that
is um
is already grooming
it's already going to be inappropriate
at best
but talk about euphemisms and uh
justifications what i just said about
the kind of the abuse exception here
which i think we would all agree if a
child is abused obviously that's that is
a time when you want to be able to talk
to the child without having the parent
involved if the parent is the is the
guilty party in the abuse
now that's another way that the left
kind of do an end run around this issue
is that uh they'll say that well
you know if the six-year-old is really
trans
and their parents aren't accepting of it
then that six-year-old is a victim of
abuse
and so we we have to rescue him from
that abuse
that's the that's the way they get
around it that's the way they dress it
up
that's the way they dress it up in
public and probably in their own minds
to rationalize what they're doing but
there's no question that uh it is
grooming and indoctrination
and it is a form of sexual abuse
by the way
um brandon summit says i love matt's
play-by-play of biden's social
awkwardness i've been there before it's
especially bad when you arrive to a
party before your core group of people
arrive
um yeah that's uh that's a problem or if
you're you know you're at the social
function and you have your core group of
people and you have your circle but they
keep fanning out and mingling with
others
like you found your people and this is
what you're gonna you know it's like
this is how we're gonna get through this
together
and then they betray you by going and
talking to other people
forcing you to also mingle that's
another that's another problem so again
that's that's the one time i've ever
felt bad or really i guess because i
could relate to biden with that footage
of him
being left all on his own while everyone
fawns over obama
um
let's see
james says
quote hey i bet i can get everyone to
celebrate a fake holiday for a fake
sexuality of self-obsessed single people
justifying their loneliness hashtag
international asexuality day
well i'm glad you brought that up james
because i i did i did forget to mention
that yesterday and i apologize to all
the asexuals out there which is a
category that really really doesn't
exist um
but yesterday was uh we had trans day of
visibility yesterday was the asexual day
of visibility
international asexuality day so
if you celebrate it then happy
asexuality day if you didn't then i
guess we'll get we'll get to it next
year
well the latest limited edition highly
sought after installment of my patch
program is here already featuring the
embroidery of two crossed banjos on a
strident orange face april's patches
reminiscent of one of my sets former
hallmarks
you may not have won the giveaway back
when i relinquished my prize banjo and
now all i have is this phantom banjo
which lives on
on the bed sheet that i do my show in
front of
but now is your chance to claim a
memento honoring my virtu virtuo is sick
virtuous why would you put a word like
that in a in a copy that i have to read
virtusic is that even a word virtusic
i don't think that's a word
virtuosic that probably is a word anyway
my virtuosic
virtuosic my virtuosic prowess plucking
the beloved instrument so go to
dailywire.com
shop to secure your piece of my patch
program or any of the other products
featured in my vast and rapidly growing
collection today now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
so we must return to a well that we just
recently visited quite a shallow well it
turns out but there's a reason to come
back here today last week we canceled
jon stewart after he focused an episode
of a show
on airing the dirty laundry of his own
personal white guilt now nobody knew
that he had done this because nobody
knew that he had a show until the clips
went viral online where he rants about
the sins of white america the evils of
the white man etc
and now he must cancel him again for a
similar reason though with a slightly
different theme
stewart is continuing his white guilt
tour this time appearing on somebody's
show or maybe they're appearing on his
who knows but during the conversation um
he said this listen
the literal interpretation of the
american dream is that is it doesn't
matter where you were born or how you
were born or who you are that in this
country you can
rise up and go beyond that and it turns
out to be a fallacy but i wonder you
know when we say oh in 2040 or 2050 when
the demographics change we won't know
what will happen
i feel like we know what will happen
because it's it's what's happened from
the very beginning and i would say yeah
the formation of the union the
compromise that was made with the
southern states that black slaves would
count as three fists but they can't vote
but you can count them there has always
been
a redistribution of power to the white
elite
the american dream is a fallacy says the
man with a net worth of 120 million
dollars
he says it's a fallacy that anyone no
matter where you're born can rise up and
go beyond that he says it's fallacious
because there is a white elite who are
constantly redistributing wealth and
power to themselves
and his example of uh and proof of this
systemic sort of rigging is the um
three-fifths compromise which was put in
place in the 1700s
and was recently repealed and abolished
and by recently i mean uh over 150 years
ago
you know once the united states became
its own official country slavery as an
institution
only survived about 90 years
as opposed to many other countries in
the world especially countries in asia
and africa which had slavery for
centuries
and kept the institution in place for in
some cases over a century longer than
the u.s
china
had slavery for i don't know about 3 000
years
didn't officially abolish it as a legal
institution until the early 20th century
but even after was abolished officially
it continued and still continues to this
day unofficially
but this sort of historical context
eludes jon stewart he drudges up the
sins of our distant past all the way
back to our nation's very infancy and
uses it as his canvas to paint a bleak
picture of america today now as far as
that goes
it's one thing for him to do the usual
song and dance about america being a
racist country etc and so forth and
that's bad enough
but i find it especially galling
when he standing on his lofty luxurious
perch waves his hand dismissively and
declares that the american dream is an
impossibility for millions of americans
a fallacy he says
now this is just not true it is it's
certainly true that some people have it
easier than others some people start out
life with advantages that other people
don't have
jon stewart's children for example have
many privileges that other people's
children
don't have um yes they're more
privileged than black children in the
inner city they're also more privileged
than white children living in a drug
infested trailer park in appalachia
somewhere
nobody is claiming that every person has
an equal shot at having success in life
whatever success might mean
if you're born in squalor
that will negatively impact your chances
and then whatever your socioeconomic
situation
some people have better natural tools
than others some people are smarter
better learners more gifted more suited
for success in certain areas lebron
james had to work hard to have success
in the nba but he certainly started off
with a better chance at that kind of
success than say i did
there's there's no way to give everyone
an absolutely equal playing field given
that everyone is different everyone's
situation is different and the playing
fields we want to play on are all also
different
not to mention we make different choices
we have different priorities etc
the question for our purposes right now
is whether there's a system in place to
grant better opportunities to white
people based purely on their skin color
and as to that the answer is clearly no
in fact all of the systems that grant
opportunity based on skin color cut
against whites not in favor of them
moreover a simple google search confirms
that what what i think most people have
just observed anecdotally
white people are not on average the most
financially successful group in the
united states
not even close actually
if the system is built to put us ahead
it seems to be massively malfunctioning
at the moment
so the the median household income for
asian americans is twenty thousand
dollars higher than the median income
for whites whites are twenty thousand
dollars higher than blacks and asians
are doubly as financially sexual
successful as blacks
a simple narrative of white privilege
doesn't seem sufficient to explain this
disparity especially when you break
asian down into its different distinct
ethnic groups
so
the median household income for indian
americans is 126
000
that's the median
that's nearly double the number for
whites
filipinos are uh 100 000
same for taiwanese indonesians clock in
at 93 000 pakistanis 87 000 chinese 85
000
many of these ethnic groups hail from
poor countries many of these uh are
americans you know who are excelling to
such an agree and they're they're second
or even first generation immigrants
they just got here and they're already
enjoying enormous success
how could that happen in a country that
is racist against non-whites and
especially as we're told racist against
non-white immigrants
well the answer is that the racism
narrative is false
once we put that to the side i think we
can have a more adult conversation about
how we might explain the incredible and
inspiring success of asian immigrants in
this country
and and we might be able to explain the
contrast between their success and the
struggles of other groups
the explanation is perhaps not simple
has many layers but i think two factors
immediately spring to the foreground
first
asians are more likely to get married
and less likely to get divorced
than pretty much any other group
second as a general rule
these various ethnicities come from
cultures that put a high premium on hard
work
so to review
they have stable families and they work
hard
in their home countries that formula
very often did not result in financial
success which is why they came here in
this country it almost always does to
one degree or another
now homing in on just the first point
here
a very interesting correlation comes
into view as you go down the median
income ladder from asian to white to
black you notice that the broken and
fatherless home rates go up
so it's almost as if the more broken
homes you have in your community the
more poverty you have in your community
fortunately we don't need to speculate
about whether there is a connection here
in fact literally every study ever done
on the subject proves that there is a
direct causal link between the state of
the family and poverty
there has never been any credible study
to my knowledge indicating that marriage
and family are irrelevant or neutral
factors when it comes to financial and
economic stability
that's how clear-cut this is
now
this connection obviously blows
stewart's simplistic racial narrative
out of the water any ethnic group can
have wild success in this country if
they keep their family unit together the
evidence for that is incontrovertible
but is he still correct that the
american dream is a fallacy whether it's
because of racism or not and it's not
the fact is that lots of people as
already acknowledged are born into
disadvantaged situations
it'll be harder for them to climb to the
top whatever and wherever the top is for
them depending on what their goals are
does this call into question the
american dream no it doesn't
here we have to rely more on experience
and observation and anecdote because
it's a very difficult thing to quantify
on a bar graph but if you look through
any of those lenses you will see example
after example of people in america
starting at the dirt bottom beneath the
bottom starting in a hole in many cases
and yet climbing their way out and
beyond far beyond through determination
and hard work
that's not some kind of myth or cliche
it actually happens all the time
it's more than possible
in fact i would go so far as to say that
if you work hard barring an act of god
like a disaster an illness of some kind
if you work hard you are virtually
guaranteed to move up from where you
started
doesn't mean everyone's going to be
billionaires almost none of us ever will
be billionaires but hard work is
absolutely one of the most crucial and
decisive factors which determines
whether a person climbs up in life or
stays stagnant or regresses it's not the
only one
and it's not easy i mean nobody said it
was easy that's why we call it hard work
but hard work does matter
now i can speak from my own experience
every person i know or who i've ever met
in my life who has achieved their goals
and found success has been a very hard
worker i i've never met an exception to
that
this can't be a coincidence it's not a
coincidence
which is why rather than the racial
stuff
what we should be talking about is why
so many especially young people in our
culture today young people of all races
seem so much to lack drive ambition a
willingness to put in the work
this is more than just the classic
complaint about kids today that every
adult in history has always had about
the next generation this is something uh
realer than that i think there there is
without question a palpable malaise and
sense of despair a pervasive lack of
vision and ambition which has gripped
hold of our society especially younger
people
being stuck in that kind of stupor will
certainly affect your ability to succeed
it will destroy it in fact
it will essentially guarantee failure
and disappointment
but the causes of this cancer aren't
systemic racism
it's rooted much more deeply than that
that's a conversation we could have
but the jon stewarts of the world make
that impossible by distracting us and
taking us off track with their incessant
evil white man narrative
and that's why jon stewart is again for
the second time in two weeks cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22. today on the ben shapiro show barack
obama returns to lie about his actions
on ukraine crackerjack becomes cracker
jill and joe biden's health and human
services secretary says he'd love to use
federal dollars for transgender
surgeries on minors so things are going
great that's today on the bench bureau
show give it a listen